they say humans have a Natural Curiosity
about other people's lives
we are social beings with social media
and digital Technologies we are
constantly sharing information about
ourselves does it mean we are constantly
being watched
in our world today is it possible to
have privacy and is there hope that we
can still protect it
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
being a performer on stage or in front
of the camera implies being exposed
it goes with the job and it's fine with
me
[Music]
because at any time I can choose to stay
away from the stage the screen and the
people and be alone
but is this Choice still available today
in the world of technology and social
media
or is there always someone spying on us
remotely installing spyware is
technically possible it happens
governments use Pegasus to Target
activists this is telepathy except this
time is for Real
it seems that today Espionage does not
just Target people with top secret
information
today we are all under surveillance
who is spying on us and how do they use
the information they gather
in our world today does privacy still
exist and there's still a chance to
protect him or have we already lost that
war
who is our audience
and how big is it
[Music]
during my research I discovered the work
of Sarah
works for the open technology fund
OTF
a non-profit Corporation against
repressive surveillance
millions of people use OTF supported
Technologies to avoid repressive
surveillance
hi Sarah how are you good how are you
doing thank you very much for talking to
me I wanted to ask you about spying
what are the different methods that are
available today to spy on us
um so there are a lot of different ways
to spy on people if you
if it's or the surveillance capitalism
let's say that's the type of
surveillance that happens by commercial
companies uh it's how they collect data
from you they know your habits they know
your searches and then they sell this
information to other ad agencies and
tech companies and all that there's a
different type of surveillance uh one
that is in the name of Public Safety
that governments and law enforcement
agencies do so that's surveillance
cameras official recognition technology
and then there's also surveillance
that's basically meant to Target certain
people so you can think of stalker wear
or spyware that's used to Target for
example
um Partners to use the target
journalists used to Target activists
basically anyone that is considered a
threat to individuals what is stock
aware that is what you think of when you
think of hacking so tapping into phone
lines hacking devices infecting laptops
an example of that is is basically
Pegasus can you talk to me about the
Pegasus case Pegasus is an incredibly
invasive and sophisticated spyware that
is developed
in many cases we've seen is that
governments use Pegasus to Target
activists human rights Defenders
journalists lawyers and sometimes heads
of state as well do you think
information and data have become the new
oil
and we are the wells information and
they are basically the most lucrative
thing about us in today's digital world
and it is definitely a currency that all
of these uh companies are are using and
taking advantage of and exchanging
between each other so yes definitely
I'm sorry I didn't understand your
question do you want to check crude oil
prices the location of the nearest gas
station
no
can I help you I'm listening
[Music]
yes they are listening
but with no previous warning
how many more doors to our privacy are
we voluntarily leaving open
[Music]
and is it really voluntary
are we consenting to surveillance
or do they just not care about our
consent
warning if you unplug
what is the solution do we stop using
technology and live in isolation or is
there a way to use technology and
preserve our privacy at the same time
[Music]
man believe me there is no other way
should I just live in isolation then
I am sure we have other choices other
than just to open or close more
solutions are found at the midpoint
even this planet Earth that we are on
doesn't just have a north and Southport
you have the equator line no actually
those things they don't have an equator
and what makes you so sure are you can
say in past experience feeling but in
those things
there is no equator
[Music]
in order to know more I will talk to
Martine gluten
a consultant in digital security
and coordinator of the Coalition against
spyware
hi Martin thank you for taking the time
to talk to me
before we start our discussion I would
like to ask you if there are any
precautions I should be taking to
protect the privacy of this conversation
to make sure this conversation is
private it's important that we check
that end-to-end encryption is enabled in
the software that we're using and some
software hasn't enabled by default and
that makes it very good you have to
think about it
others don't some have it as an optional
and we need to um then you need to make
sure it's enabled
okay
two more recommendations just to keep
you extra safe always install updates
and secondly only downloads programs
videos and music from official sources
okay
what about privacy agreements and terms
and conditions do these ground the
corporations illegal back door to misuse
our information without us knowing it
unfortunately the Agreements are often
written in very general terms that gives
them a lot of leeway now I don't think
that Facebook or Google is directly
selling your data they don't need to
your data may still end up being sold in
in more complex Ways by using apps that
have software inside them that track
your location and that location is then
sold uh sort of anonymously sometimes
sometimes not it's a very shady business
what about the fear that someone
remotely installed stock aware on my
mobile phone
is that an exaggerated fear or does it
happen more than we believe remotely
installing spyware is technically
possible it happens but it's very
expensive so it only really happens to
people with very powerful enemies so to
say think of journalists activists in in
many parts of the world human rights
Defenders average people don't have to
worry about that when it comes to their
own phone and account
the risks to our privacy are many
but there are also many ways to protect
ourselves against them
and this is good
I've never been afraid to speak up when
I have something to say
but I'm also careful to control what I
want to share
there are limits between what I consider
public and private
it happens to me a lot that I feel they
could hear us when we talk
but what really scares me is that
sometimes I feel they can listen to my
thoughts
how did they know I am thinking of the
Equator
am I taking this too far
am I being paranoid
or can they really read minds
even if they can't read minds today
one day future technology make it
possible
this idea scares me
[Music]
just like I was scared when I heard that
a primary school in China made their
pupils wear headbands that thread brain
signals
teachers were monitoring people's
attention using an app which received
real-time data
this might be the last and definite
invasion of our minds
but will it actually happen
will technology one day be able to spy
on our thoughts
find the answer I talked to Rafael yuste
director of neurotechnology Center at
Columbia University
hi Rafael how are you doing hi a green
from New York thank you for talking to
me I wanted to ask you what is
neurotechnology neurotechnology are
tools and methods to do two things to
record the activity of neurons in the
brain or to change the activity of
neurons in the brain so is that
technology going to read our mind
it is scary but it is natural our brain
uh has a lot of neurons about the 100
billion neurons
and they're connected in very
complicated circuits that we haven't
deciphered so everything that we are as
humans
it's actually
generated by the firing of this neural
circuits so that's why we need
neurotechnology we need these methods to
be able to get into this this black box
figure out what's going on understand
how it works and then we will be able to
go to the patient and really help them
and this is not science fiction this is
something that already happens in
laboratory animals what's possible today
with mice will be possible with humans
tomorrow
can you tell me what is a brain computer
interface it's neurotechnology device
that you can use inside your head in
this case is invasive or you can put on
top of your head in this case it's
non-invasive
and this connects
your brain to a computer
or to an external machine so this uh
brain computer interfaces that we call
bcis are used for example in the clinic
to help patients that have for instance
paralysis or have a lock-in syndrome so
what kind of industrial uses are there
for brain computer interfaces so I'm
sure they're going to be used for gaming
so you know there's a lot of virtual
reality gaming they can also be used for
typing for example later we will have
Technologies to be able to write brain
activity non-invasively
and those could be used not just to
decode but to bring new information into
the brain you could imagine doing a
Google search in your head also you
could be able to use algorithms from
artificial intelligence that are running
on super computers outside to help your
decision making and we're concerned
about this we're very concerned about
this and that's why we think that this
is a human rights issue so what's the
next step if we can decode speech
and we can write information into the
brain maybe in a couple of decades you
and I will be having this conversation
mentally without opening our mouth so
this is telepathy except this time is
for real this is what's coming
[Music]
I can always Retreat to a corner of my
mind a private space free from any
intrusion
if they could read our minds nothing
would prevent them from writing on them
this is really scary
it is not just reading our mind it is
writing it
brainwashing with a press of a button
[Music]
thinking of this can just drive me man
it is a nightmare that I must not
surrender to
because I must live like everyone else
thank you
[Music]
yes I should take care
try to read between the lines
but I should never be paranoid
[Music]
when I'm on stage I am exposed and I
know that I'm exposed
this does not stop me from speaking
but I'm always aware
that there is an audience listening
and when I use the internet
I'm also exposed that too does not stop
me from speaking
but it is important that I measure what
I say and to know that there could be
another audience listening
and when I want my privacy
I run away to my personal space far away
from the audience and technology and
think and contemplate and then return to
my normal life with a few answers and
many more questions
[Music]
foreign